all right
so
look
i got
spots all right
all right
okay
uh
so
hmm
wow
well
fresh books
hey
okay
uh
so
oh
come down
down
five
now
okay
together
i might have three because you're
helping me
but don't sit
here
responsive
up
down
don't use this thing
up the center very down
move the other hand out of the way
that hand brace did you feel licensed
hey no
counterweight your head with your legs
you're going like this
all the center down
underneath
make sure
julian your feet stink do you wear
sandals to the dojo
nowhere sandals my warrior wears
saddles
uh
make sure you come down go up and you
come down
calm down
ah on the line
good
thank you
make sure you come down
oh
down
only four reps
keep your mind
roll it
no
that way
you